with so many rumors and news tidbits
floating around it could be tough
keeping track of what's going on in the
MCU and what's coming up well strap on
your vibranium shield because we're
hitting you with every project you can
expect to see in phase four of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we've been
promised it would happen for years and
on May 1st 2020 it finally well-liked
widow in which Scarlett Johansson will
reprise her role of super spy Natasha
Romanov for what very well might be the
last time the prequel is set in the
period between Civil War and the
infinity war but will likely also flash
back to the time before mom announced
recruitment by shield
according to director Kate shoreland
that the flick will find Romanoff in a
dark place following courage she quotes
puts the pieces of herself together and
comes out a whole person much of the
action will take place overseas and yes
we may finally get to find out what went
down in Budapest
Johansson co-stars include Florence Pugh
and Rachel vice who will appear as
operatives who have also undergone the
same Red Room training that honed
Romanovs deadly skills also starring as
david harbour who will portray the red
guardian russia's answer to captain
america rounding out the cast will be OT
[ __ ] ben lay as marcus an underworld
fixer and Ray Winstone whose role is
undisclosed it's not yet known who will
be playing the flicks reported villain
taskmaster whose photographic reflexes
allow him to perfectly mimic the
fighting style of anyone he faces
another long-rumored project to receive
the final confirmation at San Diego
comic-con 2019 was a Disney Plus limited
series the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
which will see Anthony Mackie and
Sebastian Stan reprising their roles of
Steve Rogers two best buddies who just
happened to kind of hate one another
can you move you Sheena no perhaps the
announcements biggest reveal is a slow
go which sports are very Captain America
asked design it seems that some will
some will have a bit of reconciling to
do between his old heroic identity and
the new identity bequeathed to him by
Rogers himself for the conclusion of
Avengers endgame plot details of so far
been kept under wraps but we do know one
thing
the 6 episode series will see the return
of Zemo the man who goaded the Avengers
into the titular conflict of Captain
America Civil War and he'll be sporting
his distinctive purple mask from the
comic Carrie Skoglund would direct every
episode with writing duties being
handled by
CIM Spellman and Derrick Kolstad the
series won't be part of the original
offerings Disney Plus will feature at
launch but it is expected to hit the
streamer sometime in mid to late 2020
Marvel Studios open their comic-con
panel with discussion of the Eternals an
interesting if lesser-known property
which should help anchor the cosmic side
of the MCU moving forward the titular
race of super-powered beings were
created eons ago by the Celestials to
defend the earth when they're polar
opposites the deviants Marvel head
honcho Kevin Feige has teased that the
eternal story may span quote tens of
thousands of years telling an epic story
of the type we haven't seen in the MCU
the movie which will be directed by the
writer Homer Chloe Jiao has assembled a
suitably epic cast for its November 6
2020 release the Eternals will star
Richard Madden as Icarus alongside him
as Angelina Jolie as Xena
Kumail Nanjiani as king go Lauren
Riddler Fez McCrory Brian Tyree Henry as
Fastow's Salma Hayek as a Jack and Leah
McHugh as the trickster sprite the
starring vehicle for the MC used first
Asian superhero movie protagonists
shang-chi master of Kung Fu was teased
in late 2018 but until the title was
released at San Diego comic-con in july
2019 its iconic villain had only been
rumored it turns out that the rumors
were true
Shang Chi and the legend of the ten
rings will see the supremely skilled
fighter facing off against the Mandarin
the classic Iron Man villain who had
been cruelly teased with Ben Kingsley's
impostor actor Trevor Slattery in Iron
Man 3 don't you got a minute to live to
look with words of course the Marvel
one-shots all hail the king revealed
that the real deal was still out there
somewhere and now he'll finally make his
presence known it seems that the ten
rings a terrorist organization who
kidnaps Tony Stark and Iron Man will
figure prominently into the screen
origin of shang-chi who in the comics is
perhaps the finest unarmed combatant in
existence destined Daniel [ __ ] has
been tapped to direct with Chinese
Canadian actor C mu Lee you holding down
the title role also confirmed to be
starring awkwafina in an undisclosed
role and legendary Chinese actor Tony
Leung as the Mandarin rumors have
already began swirling that a nefarious
body will be retcon to Shanti's father
in the flick but for now this is
unconfirmed we'll find out when it's
released February 12 2021 when it was
first announced in late 2018 that Marvel
Studios would be developing multiple
limited series for the
new Plus streaming service it didn't
take long to get confirmation on the
first of these a show about Loki which
will see Tom Hiddleston returning to
portray the beloved trickster God once
more well plot details remain scarce
Hiddleston did appear during Marvel
Studios panel at San Diego comic-con to
confirm a spring 2021 release for Loki
hinting that the series were answer fans
questions about where the Avengers era
Loki went with the tesseract after
disappearing during endgames time heist
of course the character met a grim end
at the hands of Santos and the brutal
opening sequence of Avengers infinity
war and his death is expected to
actually take this time according to The
Hollywood Reporter the series will
follow Loki as he quotes pops up
throughout human history as an unlikely
influencer on historical events like a
less friendly time-traveling Forrest
Gump the project has scored a showrunner
who should know his way around this kind
of material Michael Waldron who has
worked as a writer on Adult Swim's Rekha
Morty and will be credited as creator
and executive producer in addition to
writing the pilot is an inspired premise
and a spot-on creative choice but let's
face it
Disney plus hottest at Tom Hiddleston
were returned as Loki
[Music]
20:16 stocked a strange gave a CMC use
first look at the multiverse so it was
only to be expected that a sequel which
has been in the works since before the
first film even released should further
explore the concept but this time around
it appears that traversing multiple
alternate realities will be central to
the plots as evidenced by the Flex title
revealed at San Diego comic-con 2019
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness returning director scott
derrickson was previously most at home
in the horror genre having helm such
flakes as The Exorcism of Emily Rose and
sinister for the further adventures of
Stephen strange derrickson has promised
that he'll deliver quote the first scary
MCU film on May 7th 2021 which sounds
like an amazing prospect but wait
there's more fans sdcc were also treated
to the announcement that the movie would
co-star elizabeth Olsen as Wonder
maximov Scarlet Witch along with her
potent and dangerous reality-warping
powers it was also revealed that the
film would tie directly into the plot of
the upcoming disty plus series one
division which will see Olsen reprise
her role along with Paul Bettany as a
probably less gray vision we expected to
see further the team ups along the lines
of the Thor Hulk pairing and thor
ragnarok for phase 4 and we must say
that this one was quite unexpected and
inspired among the more intriguing
Disney Plus limited series as one
division which will be run by Captain
Marvel writer Jack Schaeffer and will
feature the reunion of Scarlet Witch and
vision of course everyone's favorite
robot boyfriend was looking just at a
bit dead the last time we saw him during
the climax of Avengers infinity war and
he didn't return in the blip while it's
not known exactly how the avenging
Android will make his return there are a
few breadcrumbs you can follow that give
us a clue Elizabeth Olsen has said that
at least a portion of the series takes
place in the 1950s which doesn't make a
great deal of sense unless perhaps
time-travel is involved or perhaps
alternate realities this seems a bit
more likely since we know the events of
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness we'll find - the events of the
series but it could be that Wonder will
travel to another world one in which her
lost love is alive but that in doing so
somehow upsets the balance of the
multiverse leading a certain good doctor
to intervene we won't know for sure
until the series drops but it has been
confirmed that the show will take place
after the events of Avengers endgame it
be a terribly long way to discover how
it will all shake out one division is
slated to debut on Disney plus sometime
in the spring of 2021 what's if it's an
alternate universe anthology series
which has run in various formats since
1977 exploring how events may have been
folded if crucial moments in the
mainstream Marvel timeline have played
out differently
it allowed readers to consider scenarios
both intriguing what if spider-man had
joined the Fantastic Four and then
thinkable we're talking what if dr.
stranger a disciple of Dormammu well
what it did for the comics at Disney
Plus animated series what if intends to
do for the MCU like its Comics
counterparts what's here phille have an
anthology formats with each episode
tackling one specific moment in the MCU
timeline we know what you're thinking
one if star-lord hadn't picked the exact
wrong moment to cold-cocked Thanos we
can already tell you infinity war would
have been a heck of a lot shorter and
less tragic we'll have to wait and see
what we a nurse this animated outing
will have in store for us
we did get some definite hints about a
few possible scenarios during Marvel's
2019 Comic Con panel which not only set
a summer 2021 date for the show but
revealed an impressive lineup of MCU
talent set to lend their voices they
will be joined by jeffrey wright in the
central role of werter The Watcher
likely a Rod Serling like hosts for the
anthologies multiverse spanning
speculations
rounding out the first batch of Disney
Plus limited series will be Hawkeye
which we'll see Jeremy ran over prizes
for all as he avenging Archer the series
logo which is heavily inspired by the
one used on the characters while
received recent comics run from Matt
Fraction
and David Archer was dropped on a San
Diego comic-con crowd along with the
reveal came the confirmation of a
long-standing rumor that the series will
see the debut of Kate Bishop a young
protege you take to the mantle of
Hawkeye in the comics the series has
confirmed to take place after the events
of Avengers ends game so it will likely
see Clint Barton adjusting to a world in
which his beloved family has returned
from being tested in the decimation and
has trusted Ally Natasha Romanoff is no
more having sacrificed herself to
further the Avengers mission in endgame
Buono plot details were announced when a
did share one little tidbit with a
comic-con crowd which suggests that
Barton's mentorship of Bishop will be
key to the series narrative he dished I
get to teach someone else not to be a
superhero without superpowers
fans have been clamoring for this
storyline to make its way to the screen
for some time but they'll have to wait a
bit longer to see it
fruition Hawkeye is scheduled to debut
on Disney Plus in the fall of 2021 given
his fantastic character arc over his
last several appearances culminating
with his decision to join the guardians
of the galaxy at the conclusion of
Avengers endgame speculation had been
running high for some time that thought
would be the first avenger to land
himself a fourth solo film it was
confirmed in july 2019 that it was
happening with thor ragnarok striker ytt
returning to direct but at that month
San Diego comic-con further details were
announced that shocked those in
attendance specifically the flick now
officially titled Thor love and thunder
releasing November 5th 2021 we'll see
the return of Natalie Portman's Jane
Foster who will follow in a character's
recent comic-book footsteps by picking
up me on Nia to become Thor herself
Tessa Thompson will also return as
Valkyrie and Kevin Feige has confirmed
that this time around it will be made
explicit that the character is bisexual
a first for a major character in an MCU
film this along with the Flex title have
led some to speculate that the god of
thunder just might find himself in the
middle of a complicated love triangle
one involving two women who were just as
powerful as he and who may prove to be
slightly more interested in each other
than they are in him so far so awesome
but we just have one question is this a
brand new me or Nia or the same one
Captain America returned to 2013 in
Avengers end game check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]